i'd love this man uh he's the pro
football hall of famer the man who
coined the phrase football heaven when
he went into the pro football hall of
fame a first ballot man in every way
shape or form on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line here on the rich eisen show
is marshall falk how are you two wait
what's up i'm good rich how's it going
i'm better for talking to you i'm better
for talking to you what
what uh what struck your fancy in week
one because you always watch the game in
a way that that uh i i normally don't
see it as i mean all right let me let's
start with this one i'll be more
specific to you
uh what what do you think happened with
green bay against the saints um
uh
i i
saw two things
i was wondering
if if everything was okay in green bay
as far as like
for the guys really behind aaron rice so
when the guy decided hey i don't want to
be here and then you decide you're
coming back it kind of throws the team
off a little bit rich and i feel like
that has something to do with it it's
going to take a minute for them to kind
of get all hands on deck
but
all the film that they watched everybody
everything that they watched to the
sinks it had been so much dinking and
dumped in the last couple of years and
james winston actually showed them what
the long ball looked like
and you could it was it was it was like
wow sean payton
this is his office he don't have to pick
you apart
he can throw the ball over the top of
you and that it surprised green bay now
it looks like the last time we saw green
bay the temple did the same thing too
if you think about it same thing took
them deep
and uh
man
green bay got some problems aaron
rodgers said don't worry about it the
coach said it's a problem let's see
where it goes rich
so let's let's unpack that a little bit
one at a time here um so let's take the
last one first because i know you're a
sean payton whisperer always that you
always have been you go way way back to
what san diego state right you and sean
payton yeah back to the day so um
rick so
what do you think he's going to do with
jameis
that did we get a little look a little
looksy um you know obviously can't guard
mike he's now got covet he'll be back
some point off the pub what do you think
this looks like when it's all said and
done yeah i think i think jameis jameis
put the league on on high alert and it's
amazing when you get a quarterback with
the guy who can give him the answers
like he's standing up he has the answers
to what's going on
and that's just that's that's what it
looked like and we saw kind of bits and
pieces of it last year
but um man i didn't think he would come
out like this and have this opportunity
um
this is you know and and i don't know
maybe breeze was a little banged up we
didn't see a lot of the deep ball
but man to see to see the deep ball in
that offense it's it like it struck i
think the league's on on high alert like
oh my god did you guys see that because
i saw it
and then when you said uh the locker
room when somebody says i don't want to
be there
uh but i now i'm here i mean you know do
you think there were guys in the packer
locker room that took it personally and
didn't understand that it was 12's
problem was with the front office and
not them
you think no no
it's not it's not who the problem's with
which it's just like hey if you don't
want to be here you don't want to be
here
like it it it's just that you don't want
to be here and when you that that's
that's it like you're not you're not
pointing a finger at anybody
the one thing that we want to know is in
this game
that everybody that's playing here they
want to be here
that's what we want to know i mean it's
it's a you know this
we got a band together the team is close
together win together we talk all that
team camaraderie stuff but if someone's
saying
that they don't want to be there and
that someone just happened to be your
quarterback albeit business you stay out
of it you don't come another man's money
he didn't want to he doesn't want to be
there
but he said he didn't want to be there
because the front office made a maneuver
to say your time is definitely running
up here and his response was then then
get me the hell out of here if you're
not gonna put me on the
the tb 12 plan until i i'm done you know
and show you i physically can't do it
anymore you know like that's always
happens rich rich this this is how it
always happened okay you put person
versus entity and the person is going to
always be wrong
nobody nobody in green bay came out and
said aaron rodgers we don't want you you
got to go
did you hear it because i didn't hear it
no but they did make that maneuver to
make it seem like you know you're going
to go sooner rather than later you know
what maneuver was it getting jordan love
and starting the clock and knowing that
you got it my bad oh that's right rich
we can't put a competition at
quarterbacks we can drop running backs
and we can draft wide receivers and we
can draft defense alignment but hell
don't put competition at the quarterback
position oh my god but let's give them
40 million and just go out and play but
don't compete that's what you're saying
i spent a while chris brockman since i
strolled into a 28 trap it's been a long
time
i think the tackle it's a different
breed you know that but it's not
that's your guy man though i mean aaron
rodgers they draft him they draft him
after they said you know we're all
wondering can he change his spots with
his new coach and then they go 13-3 and
they were amazing and then they draft a
kid come on though marshall you know no
i don't disagree with you i don't
disagree with you
i do not disagree with you but
here here's what i'm saying yes aaron
rodgers
you were drafted late in the first round
behind brett favre and guess what farm
did continue to
play so now this doesn't fit you
two
two
and so you think part of week one had
something to do with it there's some
residue i think i think the continuity
of the teams and togetherness listen
we're we're all professionals some teams
are better than most but we're all
professionals and when you get at a high
level where you got a green bay and a
thanks plan early everybody got to be
together and that didn't look like a
together that didn't look like a team
that was together marshall faulk here on
the rich eisen show pro football hall of
famer let's talk about the rams bud boy
was that first game for stafford exactly
what the hype was all about is that what
we're gonna see you think over the next
17 weeks
i hope so man
listen rich and listen i'm gonna go i'm
on record i want people to know yes i
was not i was not i looked at staff and
i'm like okay is it detroit or is it
staff but i don't know
but sean mcmay is another one of those
guys that you put over you i mean he put
a wolf he won the game against seattle
with with wolford i mean the dude can
call some plays he can dial it up and um
and what they did
oh man that was that was beautiful that
was masterful i just i think i sent me
video text i said look man that that was
fun
like when you watch an offensive
football game that game looked fun and
um the rams had all the answers to what
the bears were doing out there
defensively and the bears ain't no
slouch on defense i know so no slouch on
defense
so they're that's indicative of what
we're going to see you think um
there's no there's no cheese right there
that we're going to actually see the
rams
they have to listen they have to
dedicate a little bit more time to the
run
because you can't you can't run play
action and not run the ball i'm still
trying to figure out why the linebackers
and the safeties were biting up when the
rams couldn't run the ball it just
you know it's just like is i i don't
understand it but at some point in time
you have to run the football better i'm
sure they know that and um when that
dynamic is added in
uh this team
it they're going to they're going to be
tough man so offensively
defensively yeah you lost some guys
but you couldn't tell they lost them
guys so who's the best team in the nfc
west marshall what do you think that's a
tough one that that that is a tough one
i mean right right now um
it's it's
i i can't really kick it like i i want
to say the rams but seattle looks good
arizona look good even the 49ers with
the musical quarterbacks they look good
i just it's it's hard to say rich i'm
i'm not going to put it out there um
actually you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna go home or i'm gonna go home with
the ram okay that's what i'm gonna do
and and nobody can say anything to me
about it i'm gonna say the rams
that's what i'm saying because
they were expected to and you know what
they had to do they had the whole serve
the other three teams in the west won
and and sunday night they had to go out
there against the bears and hold serve
and they did marshall falk pro football
hall of famer here on the rich eisen
show what do you think is going on with
matt neggie and his decision making with
fields
and is it the film room thing we're not
talking about is he seeing a line
why why wouldn't he just throw this kid
in the deep end of the pool again you
had a front row seat of peyton manning
being thrown in the deep end of the pool
and knowing how
somebody can take lumps and get better
and how we're seeing herbert in year two
and and what last year obviously meant
for him um to a year two
what do you think is going on with with
uh the bears decision making so there's
there's a part of me that want to
speculate like i know because i played
but but i'm not in their locker room
rich but here's what i do know yes
because
because
we saw this
um
he has to understand um hey matt maggie
i know you're probably being coy about
it but you're a liar when it comes to
this stuff because you told us nick
foles and mitch trubisky you did this
before you did this before
do people not understand we saw this
just last year
with nick foles and mitch trubisky he's
done this before and he stood at the
podium and said the exact same thing and
now we have two different quarterbacks
and he's doing the exact same thing
at some point in time somebody got to
say you're lying now what
now either you don't know who can run
your offense best or you can't run an
offense that's best for a quarterback
that you have
that's that that's how i look at it rich
i just i
the kid feels when he is on the field
the team looks dynamic everybody
it's like they stand up a little taller
it's just a different dynamic and if he
can't see that as a head coach and a
play caller
he's in trouble well but it's what
that's why i'm asking what do you think
it is and that's why you gave the caveat
of of you're not there right so what do
you think it could possibly be that he
has shown a
um some sort of uh inability to protect
himself because he he's he's not seeing
the field well enough or what what do
you think it is
here's what was said you know i'm i'm
listening i'm listening uh to college
work talk and here's what college work
said because college where crystal asked
all the good questions and here's what
he alluded to now
the one thing that andy dalton did was
they're often so the bear's offensive
line is not that good so what he's doing
is it's a lot of quick games yep
and you you have to be in order to run
quick game consistently consistently uh
and be good at it uh you you have to be
a little seasoned your pre-stat breeds
gotta be on you gotta know where you're
going with the ball and andy did a
pretty good job at that
um he got the ball out of his hands fast
but as you continue to play you gotta
stand in there and make throws um or you
have to be dynamic and buy some time and
get out of the pocket and andy andy
doesn't bring that to the table
chris collinsburg said
that in the preseason
justin fields held the ball the longest
in any quarterback
and
he only got that information
from the coaches for him to go watch
that because christian watching my
pre-season football i understand it's
his first game
so
this has to come from nagging him that
he's struggling with the quick game
processing thing getting the ball out of
his hands quicker
so here's guess what we do
we line up we run a little play action
we do the things that he's good at not
the things that you're good that not the
place that you're good at calling you
run the place that he's good at running
and this is the problem that i see with
nagi he wants to run an offense
that doesn't suit his best players
that's going to always get you fired
especially since if you've got to play
action well they don't have that great
of a running back hold on a minute they
actually do i mean that kid
montgomery is really good so
i mean what gives i again i'm not
there's rich rich let me let me just put
this in
you're running the ball down the ram
throw yeah which means you should be
running play action but when they pass
they're going quick game
no play action just quick game and
they're running the ball well that don't
match up
marshall faulk here on the rich eisen
show as always making us smarter all
right now i'm gonna go wide macro is
there a week one result where i
mentioned the cheese that that's the
phrase of taking the cheese like it's
out there for you to just uh to take and
then walk into the trap and then it just
you're showing to be a total fagazi is
there is there a week one result that we
should not believe either way like the
bill's losing don't believe it or
a team winning and it's just like yeah i
i still need to see more is there
anything
from week one on that front
for you mark um week one
the cheese that i would not take and and
here's the thing and uh you know i'm
hard on i'm hard on the cowboys i'm hard
yes
they're and that and i heard i've heard
michael irvin like they're finding
a victory in the loss
[Laughter]
the silver star lining yes sir yes sir
i'm just i'm just like i i get it listen
that looked
when when doc was playing well before he
got hurt this is what he looks like
right and here's here's here's my
problem that i have
tampa bay decided ezekiel elliott can
beat us we won't let him back can you
beat us
throw for 5 000 yards can you beat us
and that's what they said that's
literally what they said
and until until we see
that awesome receiving core
and
you know that do his thing consistently
nobody's going to let zebra in the ball
because they know that's the dallas
cowboys recipe to win it
and they're not going to let them cook
with the right ingredients
if they don't have to make make up make
a gourmet meal with whatever he has
they will not let this offensive line
and ezekiel elliott win ball games for
dallas so it boils down to
that and what what can he do
with what they're going to give him they
play one safety high
they ate me in box they played the
receivers a lot of man
beat me
that's what they said
so i'm i want to see i want to see what
takes place
you know with keller moore and and and
this offense and dak i want to see
because it's going to be a rough it's
going to be a rough year for ezekiel
elliot if
if the passing game can't win games for
dallas so then what can you share what
you're telling zeke uh behind the scenes
because i know you're tight with him uh
sharon man so what do you say i mean
hard he
this thing is you can't win games
without without having a passing this
this this league is too fast too strong
they're not going to just allow him to
to just carry his team on his back um
it doesn't go like that and and here's
the thing it's not like he's playing
with some inexperienced
a quarterback or some some you know
they're not that young that wide
receiver
you know this is
uh i i see the silver lining which is
just like
i and i want to see what happens i just
want to see what happens i understand
they didn't have zach martin that's a
huge loss huge loss you know he's a he's
a space creator
and um hopefully it was that
but the game plan that i saw
hey that throw it 68 times through 78
times they don't think that that can
beat them
well i mean now i mean this week in
the uh cowboys are gonna see a pretty
stout front seven again and with grown
ass man and derwin james behind it you
know i mean like that is that charges
are a good team don't you think marshall
i mean you're gonna you're gonna see the
same thing
you're literally going to see a lot of
the same thing
they're they're going to they're going
to say you have to beat us throw in the
football that's you're not you're not
just running z
that's not happening so didn't you did i
assume you had you had similar
situations thrown your way in your
career in your hall of fame
so what do you do i mean like zeke has
gotta i mean there's gonna be some times
you'd have to think he's gonna be
frustrated just look break in the huddle
and go again go again really okay again
a lot a lot of frustrated and here's the
thing they go to the line of scrimmage
with a run play call with a check with
it with a pass play on based on how the
defense in line or if the next man in
the box they're gonna be throwing the
ball
that's
you don't run plays uphill you know you
you you make sure that's what you have
to maximize every opportunity that you
have the ball and there's a there's
they're not there's there's not many
players in the league with it's not a
run pass option there's just about every
play is a run pass option unless there's
a short yardage or goal line planning
you know it's you know call it run it
and that's it
they don't have that many of those plays
what do you counsel last one for you
marshall falk how do you cancel somebody
who's your audio executive who doesn't
uh like it when he checks in with the
radio uh station network um that that
syndicates your show
and uh he wants to say hello to the guy
and the guy's kind of gruff and he's
doing business on the other end and you
look over and you see your audio
executive and mike del tufo and you can
see he's deflated before the show
how do you how do you how do you handle
that situation uh marshall you know i
and i asked someone you know that i i
respect you and emulate you in the way
that i need to know how everything
operates in in my offense so how do you
think i should handle that marshall oh
man that's a tough one man here's the
thing rich i don't think i'm i'm the i'm
the best guy to be making this decision
because i am emotionally invested in the
relationship
[Laughter]
mike you want to say hi to marshall i
know you've been bursting at the seams
this entire time
i talked to marshall after the call you
know i usually oh my god did you chat in
a long kiss goodbye yes it's a jewish
goodbye from my italian uh uh marshall's
awesome chat with marshall man i love
marshall i know all right marshall i'm a
guy man i miss you marshall i miss you
two wait let's do this more often i'll
do this as long as you oh yeah let me
know when anytime you call me out of the
bullpen i'll be ready
i told you that was his text last night
i'm like can you do uh first up tomorrow
he's like like wild thing bring me out
of the bullpen
you make my heart sing marshall thank
you for the call
take care right oh all right love you
marshall that's marshall [ __ ] everybody
boy does he know his football or what
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here